i
would say i'm praying for you but i'm an
atheist
i mean listen that's what i'll say
because i don't want to dive down this
deep
yeah they're going to be like oh my god
no i mean i would just say this
would you consider yourself a religious
person yeah i'm really surprised i
believe with jesus
christ all right so listen so the bible
all this [ __ ] i feel like it was changed
i feel like no
no no don't say you feel like it was
changed oh no it was changed
multiple times as as society evolved
all the real [ __ ] up [ __ ] would get
taken out of the bible and then they hit
you with that new version
here's the king james version this one
is less offensive than the old testament
because the old testament had a whole
lot of
[ __ ] wild ass offensive ill [ __ ] in
it what i'm saying is
i think that
i don't think all of these books that
people
live there it's all man written
right men wrote these books religion in
general
is is pretty much the root of 99
of all the wars over the years think
about it
think about what's what's going on in
palestine and israel right now
think about you could even go back to
world war two you know what i'm saying
like
a lot of this [ __ ] is all like like
religion to me is
like the black eye on society now
do i think that if somebody
needs to believe in something and it
gives them peace and they go to sleep at
night
because they i'm not gonna judge you
personally for me
i just think it's all [ __ ] but
that's just me i think it's just
man-made
i think it's it's been used to control
poor people you don't believe it's a
high power at all
so that i don't know okay my whole thing
is i don't know
but i tell you who also don't know the
[ __ ] who wrote all these books
so my thing is is that religion has been
used to control poor people
since its inception yeah think about it
man
you [ __ ] give up 10 20 what's
the best hustle to be in
rel man if i if i didn't have no morals
i would be a [ __ ] preacher because i
would be
riding around boy all these
[ __ ] got the nice
whips like yo man where's your tie that
yo
throw that in there [ __ ] being
private jets and [ __ ]
oh good no like if you really like i
don't get into the conversation but i
would just say this there
is uh a movie called religious
that bill maher made in like 2006 or
some [ __ ] i don't know it's pretty old
now
but that movie is the first movie that i
watched it kind of really i mind you
i've never been religious but i was like
yeah i'm untripping this whole time
a lot of this religious [ __ ] is wild bro
that's all i'm gonna say shout out to
everybody who's christian shouts
everybody
you know jesus probably was a real cat
you know what i mean
but again like i know god be watching my
as well and i'm not i'm not saying that
there isn't a higher power
like that we don't know about um i just
don't know
but i tell you one thing don't let these
[ __ ] aliens everyone's been
talking about lately obama just said the
other day that
ufos are real in an interview yeah so
once we realize that there's
aliens in other societies on other
planets
it's gonna poke so many holes through
all these [ __ ] religions it's gonna
make all these [ __ ]
minds blow that's all i was saying man
a lot of them do you think aliens i mean
yeah i mean aliens i believe in aliens
before i believe in [ __ ]
that that that some [ __ ] took
two of every animal and put him on a
[ __ ] giant boat
how crazy is that [ __ ] sound like a
fairy tale oh cause it is
anyway omb peasy appreciate you for
pulling up
but so big brother i had to praise jesus
christ it was so damn